[Music]
it's a monday edition of
p-f-t-o-t the spot where we talk about
the things we either didn't get to or
we would like to spend more time talking
about and the decision of the
jacksonville jaguars to wave running
back leonard fournette that's the big
news in the nfl right now it's been
announced by the team it's official he
will go to waivers
because he doesn't have four full
seasons in and you know
i'm amazed at the number of people who
are presuming that the jaguars
are tanking and that leonard fournette
being waived is evidence of it folks
they tried to trade him back before the
draft right they haven't
wanted this guy around they weren't able
to find a trade partner they brought him
to camp
and now they made the decision that
maybe they'll get lucky and someone will
claim him and they will avoid 4.167
million in cash and cap space that
otherwise
is guaranteed it's on the books unless
they
prevail in the grievance that has been
pending for a couple of years if they
try to get
that that guarantee removed
from the final year of his contract uh
it's not tanking
look why would they tank doug marone and
dave caldwell will be long gone if the
jaguars are tanking it'll be someone
else
using those draft picks there'll be
someone else building that roster this
is not a tank this is a
make chicken salad out of something else
for the jaguars and moving on from
leonard for that because
they they just don't think he fits jay
gruden's offense period
yeah i mean i i get it you know i get it
and i don't
in some ways you know i think the first
thing is yeah i understand you know jay
gruden
you know he's it's a west coast offense
maybe he wants more of the alvin kamara
you know threat out of the backfield and
the pass game type running back that's
where you hear about chris thompson
right who was in washington with jay
gruden
out of florida state he is awesome that
way you know fournette
you know anybody can use an in-between
the tacos type runner that's where i
would just push back against that notion
like well i mean do you have running
plays that run in between the tackles oh
you do well then leonard fournette can
fit in your offense
now does he fit the full scope no
certainly not there's got to be an issue
something that has arisen you know and
whether that is chris thompson getting
more snaps or somebody else getting
snaps or
fournette getting taken out in passing
situations during training camp
and that's caused them to be pissed off
or whatever caused friction here
i don't know because it's still as much
as we know he's kind of in a pain in the
butt for this organization
this is still surprising we're going 13
days before
a real football game and he's gone and i
i think yeah like you've mentioned it's
a it's a pretty steep price tag but
i think he's talented enough that
somebody is gonna pick him up on waivers
and i'll just be interested to see where
it goes
yeah and you know what we've been
talking about the teams that should be
interested could be interested maybe
we'll be interested again they have to
be willing to commit 4.167 million
and uh and and who knows look the
jaguars are banking on someone
saying we'll take it on and we talked
about washington earlier
with darius geist gone right you know it
looked like it was going to be the
adrian peterson show
would you rather put your eggs in the
adrian peterson
basket or would you rather roll with
leonard fournette in basically the same
role chris
yeah i you're right as much as it pains
me to say it
i'd probably rather go with fernette
yeah he's a lot younger and he's got a
hell of a lot
more of an upside right now no doubt i
think that's that's the big thing i mean
yeah adrian peterson's a legend first
ballot hall of famer one of the greatest
i've ever seen i don't think he's as
good as leonard fournette is right
now i mean leonard fournette at his size
with his power
he's still i mean he had an 80-something
yard touchdown last year
you know he's a home run hitter that way
you know we've seen him last year in
games
the broncos right he took over the game
they're just again i go back to one of
my old phrases that i like to say
there ain't a lot of people on earth
built like leonard fournette who can
move the way he can
so that's where he's a special commodity
and uh
yeah it's just i'm shocked that this has
come to this as far as you know the
jaguars just releasing them
but yeah washington you know and then
you go through a few teams
i don't think like picks two three or
four in the draft
detroit they got two running backs you
said it on the show andre swift his
heart though
right so maybe they'd want to go there i
don't know but i i doubt that with
thinking he might be back at some point
the giants of saquon barkley i'm with
you there i don't think that happens the
bangles of joe mixon
no the dolphins that pick five and the
chargers at six are the first two teams
i look at to go oh
they might be interested yeah i agree
with you especially because there's
already a sense that he's going to end
up in new england if he passes through
waivers entirely
so the best way for the dolphins to keep
that from happening
is to squat on leonard fournette when
you have the opportunity to do so he
makes the quick trip from jacksonville
to miami and brian flores you know
you make that investment for one year
and and it's
you're spending 4.1 million dollars to
evaluate the player and see if he's your
future at the position yeah
plain and simple and he did have a good
year last year
and maybe this is the wake up call he
needs maybe this is
and this is an extreme example
right maybe this is 30 years later
the philadelphia eagles all he does is
catch touchdowns decision to wave chris
carter
maybe it's the same thing where this is
what wakes him up now chris carter had
different issues in leonard fournette
but maybe this is the wake-up call you
know teams always want
the guy to get his wake-up call while
he's still on the team
you don't want his redemption to come
you don't want that great second act to
come
with a second team especially if it's a
team in your division
or team you're gonna have to deal with
on a regular basis but you know this
could be
this isn't just throw out the trash this
just could be the jaguars at their wits
end
trying to avoid that four million
dollars recognizing he's not going to be
with the team next year when they really
try to load the cannon
let's go ahead and unload him and save
the money and let someone else jump on
this guy and maybe he ends up being a
good player somewhere else yeah no
i see where it goes you know okay
what about you think the jets do you
think the jets would take a
fire on them with le'veon bell in that
situation of frank gore at his age
that's a lot of money running back
position because they're not getting
away from le'veon bell
unless they trade unless they trade the
jets
unless they trade le'veon bell uh to the
jaguars which i doubt the jaguars are
going to want to do
it just seems like too much money what
about the raiders yeah they got josh
jacobs
would the raiders be interested in
fournette i i can't imagine i mean i
would feel like you know if jay gruden
wouldn't want a fournette in his offense
i'm sure he's called his brother to go
i don't want this guy in my offense so i
don't know if you're going to want them
in your offense which is similar to mine
right so i can't imagine that plus i i
think jacobs is
so the guy now the other team that you
look at here as you start to go through
waivers and you start to think about
top picks in the draft you know the
tampa bay buccaneers got
running back i know they got lashawn
mccoy it's you know i know
mccoy right exactly jones is their guy
ronald jones jones
they drafted the kid vaughn out of
vanderbilt in the middle rounds right
so i i mean you know again i'm just
throwing teams out there where i could
go okay well i listen i know leonard
fournette's better than ronald jones i
know that
now do you want to deal with it do you
want to pay him the money that's a whole
different thing
but it's just a team that i could see at
least go and i go ah that makes sense
but after you get to that then i feel
like we don't really think about anybody
until pittsburgh again
and pittsburgh had yeah i don't know why
anybody else in between there you think
i got the eagles here i got the eagles
no
the rams the rams uh who do they have
yeah they got they got a guy-headed
monster because no one is stepping up
right they got the cam acres the darrell
hender
you know the kid um from memphis
henderson henderson yep right so i mean
i've heard cam akers has been doing well
out there uh i
but you're right that's another team you
throw out there i didn't get to the
eagles yet just because i knew they were
in the playoffs and pittsburgh would
have the waivers before them
but uh i i i could maybe see the rams i
mean
we even talked about the bears it's the
best i didn't see pittsburgh
on i didn't see pittsburgh on the list
because they're not on the draft list
because they sent their first round pick
to miami so yes this
the steelers are ahead of the eagles so
you're right they would have dibs over
philly
um what about the bears though they
would have dibs over both of those teams
yeah
i mean the bears to me that would be
something i'd be thinking about
uh now i mean i know they like and i'm
pulling up their roster as we go but we
know david montgomery got hurt
um i am one that is not necessarily the
highest
on david montgomery as far as a football
player he i wouldn't want him to be my
starting go-to guy
but i i feel like they maybe feel
differently about that but to me that
would definitely be an upgrade
as far as david montgomery to leonard
fournette let me self-correct myself
here the bears are actually one spot
behind the steelers neither the bears
nor the steelers had first round picks
last year the bears because of the
khalil mack trade right
from two years ago the steelers because
of the make of fitzpatrick trade the way
that it falls
steelers would have been 18 bears would
have been 19.
steelers have dibs over the chicago
bears
so uh i i think if he's and here's the
thing here's how it works
you you don't it's not like you sit
around the room and the bengals go first
and then the next one
no you put in your claim right and and
they used to
publish who made the waivers claims now
it's very
very guarded but for one like this i
think this is one where
hopefully someone will blab about all
the teams to put in waivers claims chris
because there's a chance
what's the over under on waiver claims
four and a half i'm gonna yeah i'll take
the over i'm i think it's gonna be about
five
six teams that that that that go
that go for him i'm gonna go for this
all right yeah you're gonna go under or
over
pete says under i say under you say over
four and a half
okay what happens we won't know until
wednesday let's try to remember
pete keep us honest uh we will have
moved on to something else by then but
but
how many teams made a waiver claim on
leonard fournette the over under is
four and a half uh we'll put that on
twitter and get your thoughts as well
all right
um jaguar's running back situation as we
said chris thompson is
is flashing but he's five eight he's not
gonna be the every down guy
there are other running backs out there
dante freeman's available
yeah there are there are some somewhat
recognizable names there always are
recognizable names at running back
because there are guys that
we used to love to have on our fantasy
football teams that just don't have it
anymore
is there anybody that comes to mind for
you is there somebody i mean i'm
thinking is there a connection to marone
is there a connection
to jay gruden is there somebody that
would make sense
uh for the jacksonville jaguars um you
know if if washington would get leonard
fournette
could they trade adrian peterson to the
to the jaguars
who that makes sense who knows you know
and the crazy thing with the running
back position is
you you don't you know but this is where
no preseason stinks we get no
context clues but i i wouldn't be
shocked if a guy
i know that was like that i love coming
out in the draft is already on their
roster
ryquelle armstead from temple you know i
think they had plans to play him last
year and he got hurt early in the year
but i think he could be an actual guy
mike in my draft rankings two years ago
okay
uh i had this guy as this i thought he
was the second best running back coming
out in the draft i thought he was damn
good football player
so we'll see maybe he's on the roster
but as far as guys that are out there on
the street right now
i there's nobody that pops off to me as
i sit here and think about it to where i
just go oh
that would make sense to get him in
there and get him you know jay gruden
x running backs is there anybody else
we're missing out there that's what i'm
just trying to think and i'm
trying to pull up a list of some guys
here as we go yeah i'm doing the same
thing
just and it's it's it's hard because the
list is picked over it's hard to find a
list of guys
currently available um but freeman
freeman is out there he was cut by the
falcons earlier this year he's been
waiting and waiting and waiting
marshawn lynch is available yeah i i
have a feeling he will not be playing
for the jacksonville jaguars but there
are some guys out there you hear the
name you're like oh yeah he's still
around but that doesn't mean that it's
gonna work
right uh and it maybe they just go next
man up i mean look you don't make this
move
if you're not comfortable with the guys
that you currently have i think
what they do i think that's that's
that's it i think between the things
you've heard about chris thompson he's
talented as hell
and then maybe one of these other guys
that just we don't know about that's
impressed them enough to go
hey the hell with this headache of
leonard fournette let's just get him the
hell out of here and move on with our
football team
didn't we mention fournette earlier in
the show when we were talking about
guys who uh who who
leave school early or should have left
school early i mean i always think of
him with you
know clowning you brought him up first
clowney was the first one that should
have sat out a whole year
and then fournette should have sat out a
whole year because i feel like in that
last year
uh there's a certain amount of of of of
a tentative quality
that creeps into that game and i'm not
saying it carried over fernet to the nfl
but he's never been at the nfl level
the guy remember when when he emerged on
the scene at lsu
we're like this is the next jim brown
this is the guy that's going to take the
nfl by storm and
obviously that hasn't happened no it
hasn't but you know again i
i think the guy's more talented and
physically gifted than he gets credit
for
you know again the first two years of
his career there was 10 people at the
line of scrimmage going blake bortles
can't throw it four feet so we don't
care
we're gonna stop blending four and they
still kept running leonard fournette
you know so he's never had that and then
of course he himself has caused some
bumps in the roads as well
but man i just i challenge anybody you
know go back watch some of his highlight
runs
they're pretty special you know as far
as what he can do
and and i don't think we've seen the
best of what he can really do because he
hasn't been put in a
a spot that can support him enough yet
to really just let it unleash so
we'll see that's what i'm betting on but
uh i've been wrong before and we'll see
where that goes
he had a 90-yard touchdown run against
the steelers as a rook he had that
81-yarder last year he
had over i'm doing the math here real
quickly
1600 yards from scrimmage last year 1600
yards from scrimmage right and he's
available
yeah and he's young he's got three years
of nfl wear and tear and he's big and
he's strong and
remember when we talked about him that
was a day you were on the show
we had the video of him and he looked
like batman yeah
remember that oh i was scared i was i
was
it that the video intimidated me he's
the guy
he is huge he is he's he's a freak of
nate it's why you
you're talking about it mike i mean it's
why
he was one of those guys where after his
redshirt freshman year you went
he could leave for the nfl right now
he's ready you know and and really it
became an underwhelming last year at lsu
because he got a really bad
high ankle sprain early in the year and
he had a fight with that
all year and it led to some
underwhelming
games early on in that year that i think
hurt his stock to a degree
but we'll see where it goes from here i
really do i think that
some team could get a gem right here as
far as a steal on waivers that can
really improve their football team
and for those of you that didn't see it
that day when you when you know that
that
phony batman chest plate that is all
chiseled
fernette was talking with something that
was kind of both tight and loose fitting
yeah it's black like one of those black
getting shaped shirts that like keeps
the sweat in almost or something
and and and you could see the outline of
the batman
fake chest plate although i assume
he wasn't wearing the fake batman uh
ben affleck costume under that shirt
that that's really how he's built and
and man
you know he's he's got the potential to
be really good here i
i uh i this is something
and uh it's going to make for a fun
tuesday because it is
and and and look here's the other thing
too i mean it's been officially
announced
you know we we we see from time to time
yeah
that there will be a a report
or an announcement that a guy is being
released now i don't know that the
jaguars can take it back now that
they've
officially announced it but how many
times have we seen guys
gonna be released and then before the
end of the day he's traded traded right
that happens that happens all the time i
i i can see that
you smoke them out smoke them out and
try to get uh
uh you know try to get uh uh somebody to
give something conditional seventh round
pick the honorary ross tucker pick
uh anything yeah um which which makes me
think
you know chris back to our over under
you say over i say under i'm more
inclined to say under i think if there
were
four or five teams that were likely to
make a waiver claim
somebody would say we'll give you a
seventh round pick for this guy's
contract i would think so too
you're right i mean you're right it just
i wonder
how much conversations have gone on with
jacksonville trying to trade him those
are things that yeah i don't know
uh try to find out but yeah i mean
i i really think this could be the kind
of guy
by the end of today you know he can make
you look differently in a team
like or like i said if the pittsburgh
steelers get them off of waivers or
somehow get them i'm going to look at
pittsburgh and go whoa
whoa you know mike might need to put the
steelers like three spots higher on his
power rankings that's going to change
the thought of
how they run their offense how dangerous
they are and what they can do
you know he to me is a game changing
type player for especially a team that's
a
playoff caliber fringe type football
team
yeah you know i'm looking into this
question of whether or not they are
prevented from
basically keeping him and trading him
even though they've announced
yeah that i would think you could not
official until four okay right
right it's not official until four
o'clock right so
i i uh you know it's not that big of a
conspiracy
who's saying that hey hey matt matt
casey's not producing the show today
matt casey mind your own damn business
it's not a conspiracy
it happens all the time it doesn't see
it happen
it was the the running back from the
dolphins right right they're waving him
oh they traded into the jets yes
it happens all the time yes caitlyn
bellagh
failed his physical and had to go back
to miami right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports